the democrat party is a machine
right now i'm reading a wonderful
biography of chester arthur
one of my favorite presidents he's not
the most well known he's mostly known
for his mutton chops but i'm reading
about chester arthur you know in the
19th century both political parties
operated with machines patronage they'd
buy votes they'd
shake down the government workers to
work for the party and both parties did
it but the democrats really perfected it
the most famous political boss in
american history is boss tweed the most
famous machine in american political
history is tammany hall that was the
democrat machine
the machine is still operating
okay the machine
we like to flatter ourselves that all
the bad stuff that people did in the
past in politics we've totally cleaned
that up that doesn't exist anymore and
now everything's operating above board
and that's our democracy our sterling
stellar pristine democracy is operating
just as it should but that's not the
case
the democrats are still especially the
democrats republicans don't really have
a very well functioning machine right
now but the democrats do and that would
be blm and it's a shakedown racket and
they shake down the big corporations and
they raise 90 million dollars and they
pay off their cronies
and they pay off the stormtroopers on
the street and they pay off
just about everybody and it all operates
in a way that you have the entire
society working in concert to advance a
political message the media the news
media hollywood big tech the
universities
the the bureaucratic government the
elected government they're all working
together the corporations is it the way
they're working together
is because of a coordinated very
effective machine the sort of thing you
would have seen 150 years ago in
american politics you're still seeing it
today
it makes me think
in a slightly separate way but go with
me for a second makes me think of the
cia
makes me think of some of the
intelligence agencies
we today we all
look back and we remember all the shady
things that the intelligence agencies
have done they were invading foreign
countries toppling foreign governments
performing all sorts of experiments on
american citizens oh my mk ultra all
these crazy experiments gosh can you
believe they did that in the past i bet
they don't do any of that anymore though
right that's what people will say yeah
you know all of these institutions they
did a lot of shady dodgy things in the
past but they totally don't do any of
that anymore and it's all completely
cleaned up and different now
uh why
what would ever make you think that
that these institutions that have been
doing things for a very long time just
suddenly overnight stopped doing all the
bad things entirely
i don't buy that
and if we don't buy that with i don't
know an intelligence agency or something
like that why would we buy it with a
political party the more things change
the more they stay the same
so the way a machine works is you got a
carrot and you got a stick
the carrot is when you grease the wheels
the carrot is when you pay people off
the carrot is when you give people
favors in patronage the stick is when
you punish people for for crossing your
machine and you're seeing that right now
the new democrat stick is accusing any
conservative
anyone who in any way calls out their
plans
of being a racist the worst thing that
you can possibly be called in america
today is a racist and so they wield this
very effectively and very loosely
one of the most important strategies for
the democrats
is mass migration
they have relied on mass migration
because statistically speaking new
immigrants and their kids and their
grandkids are much more likely to vote
for democrats than republicans and
republicans are making huge inroads with
hispanic voters that's true and
republicans
maybe in the future can make even more
inroads and republicans have long told
ourselves that latinos are
are republican they just don't know it
yet and we say all these sorts of things
but the numbers just don't bear it out
okay even with the massive shift from
hispanic voters to the republican party
in recent years
it still
gives a huge advantage to democrats and
if you if you say that now if you say
that democrats are obviously using
immigration policy to
to
change the electorate change the
demographics of the country in a way
that they think will give them an
advantage you're called a racist awful
conspiracy theorist this is what joy
reid just said the other day they're
they're exploiting the shooting in
buffalo to attack tucker carlson in
particular because he's the most
prominent conservative television host
but really all of us everyone who has a
conservative podcast everyone who has a
conservative radio show everyone who's
an elected conservative or or just down
there at the grassroots level going to
your local republican meeting you are
being called a racist terrible evil
awful person who's responsible for a
shooting in buffalo because you're
calling out their strategy
no singular voice in right-wing media
has done more to elevate this racist
conspiracy theory than tucker
who even with a new head writer spends
night after prime time night injecting
the rot from the dregs of the internet
directly into the veins of republican
voters are tucker's writers sourcing his
show from 4chan
these are just questions
as the new york times analysis last
month found in more than 400 episodes
tuckham's has amplified the idea that a
cabal of elites want to force
demographic change through immigration
that is replacement theory tucker's not
some deep thinker
he's clearly just channeling the gross
stuff his viewers could easily find
online then feeding it to republican
voters and republican politicians as
infotainment
and that feedback loop has terrifying
reach that murderous low life in buffalo
wouldn't even have to listen to tucker
he wouldn't have to watch him at all to
get it if they are essentially pulling
from the same source material
it's terrible disgusting evil false lies
propaganda the lowest of the low kind of
disinformation trash this idea that
elite people in our ruling class are
using immigration policy to change the
electorate so that they can get
political who would ever suggest such a
thing
it seems harder and harder to ignore
that the echoes of replacement theory
and other racially motivated views are
increasingly coming out into the open in
a few years we're going to be a majority
brown country white people will not be
the majority in the country anymore this
will be the first generation ever in
american history uh in which whites will
be a minority of the generation at some
point as of 2007
every year babies being born in this
country whites now with a minority in
2044
everyone is going to be a minority as
the demographics change as white people
become the minority in the country which
is coming demographics is destiny
demographics is destiny demographics is
destiny right the country is changing
i've been saying it here other people
been saying it here for years now even
before donald trump the demographics
is destiny the white population is
declining for the first time in history
in america while the number of
multi-racial americans
have more than doubled so we live in a
country where the demographics are
changing it's becoming less white
correct okay you'll be announcing that
we're calling the 38 electoral votes of
texas for the democratic nominee for
president it's changing it's going to
become a purple state and then a blue
state because of the demographics
because of the population growth
this goes on
for like another minute okay this goes
on and on and you see julian castro he's
saying look and it's going to totally
give us the win it's going to give us
texas which was one of the red estates
and it's because of people outside of
texas by which we mean mexico by which
we mean latin america and then joe
scarborough he says demographics is
destiny whoa cool it with the racist
great replacement theory there joe all
right i don't need this much racism in
my morning it's all the democrats who
have been spreading this
bragging about it for years those are
just the people on tv i could pull up
countless articles from left-wing think
tanks from left-wing newspapers not only
observing this fact but explaining how
this fact is due to mass migration which
is a very specific policy from very
specific lawmakers who are democrats for
a very specific purpose they're cheering
it on because they think that it will
give them an electoral advantage
and it's our fault because they told us
what they were doing they're doing a
thing to put themselves in power they
think permanently then they're telling
us that they're doing that thing and
then when we
repeat to them the thing that they just
told us they called us racist for
repeating it i am so glad that you liked
that clip now
you got to smash that button and ring
that like and jiggle that doodad and
make sure that you get the notifications
for the michael knowles show then you
can head on over to wherever you get
your audio podcasts for free not gonna
cost you a penny
spotify stitcher google play apple
podcast wherever type in the michael
knowles show you scroll you find you see
my swarthy sultry face you click on it
you subscribe you leave a five star
review at least i hope
and then we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you